hey guys Pete here so San Diego
comic-con is going on right now
in Game of Thrones released a longer
trailer that someone managed to upload
so this has stuff from the entire season
so if you're trying to avoid future
scenes and things like that then this
could be spoilers but it's not that much
different than the ones we saw before
the season started I usually put the
trailer in the beginning when I do
trailer breakdowns but I'm not sure this
one is okay to circulate like that so
I'm just going to use the screenshots
and go frame by frame and talk about
what we've seen so it starts with a
voiceover it's Daenerys and she tells us
I was born to rule the Seven Kingdoms
and I will while she's saying that we
see a shot of a boat landing at
Dragonstone
it's too far away to make out who it is
for sure although I have some ideas and
we get a nice shot of the dragon flying
by Dragonstone we see that shot that we
saw of Daenerys looking over the fleet
that we saw on the last trailer for
episode 2 she turns around and then we
cut to the throne room and the Iron
Throne
and we get a voiceover from another
queen and she says the mad Kings
daughter will destroy the realm we must
stand together if we hope to stop her
it's Cersei of course and we see a
close-up here of the crowd and it
actually was Randall and dick and Tarly
that were standing in the throne room
there they were the only people that I
thought I might have noticed in the last
trailer but it was so blurry and
Randall's outfit just I just didn't
think that he'd be dressed like that but
yeah we have randyll Tarly and dick in a
nice close-up of them we have a couple
shots of Cersei on the throne and then
we see the Lannister army getting ready
to march in the field so this is stuff
that we saw in the winter is here
trailer we had a couple shots of them
and then we cut back to the yard at
Winterfell there we see people training
kids to go to war there's even a girl in
one of these
those here and then we see the extended
version of what they're talking about
when we saw Yan Royce talk about the
Targaryen can't be trusted we see that
John actually says they don't have
enough people to fight the white walkers
more or less and that they need Daenerys
because she has dragon flame so he
actually brings up getting together with
Daenerys in the scene and that's when
Lord really says a Targaryen can't be
trusted and this there's a seek you know
there's definitely funny implications
there because you know he's talking to a
Targaryen but John doesn't know that and
neither does he
we also see a shot a little finger in
this and he is watching soaking in all
the conflict that's arising like he's
just looking for ways to get rid of John
so he can put Santa into place then
we've got a shot of Davos he's talking
to Santa and he says if we don't band
together then we'll die so it's likely
here that he's talking about going south
about their trip south Santa is probably
not down with the idea of joining up
with Daenerys or with the crown for that
matter but Davos always being the voice
of reason tells it tells her how it is
basically we then see Queen Daenerys on
her throne again and that cuts directly
to Cersei rising from the iron throne
and we can see that you're on Greyjoy is
there on bended knee not really sure
what's happening in this like she's
getting up I don't know if she's getting
up because something happened in the
hall there or if she's getting up to
contemplate his proposal then we get a
little Lyanna Mormont she tells King Jon
Snow winter is here your grace we see
him turn around and look we see this
clip of the dagger being sharpened again
we've seen that a couple times before
and then we see the unsullied rushing
into the yard at Casterly Rock a quick
cut to John choking Littlefinger again
and then we see Lannister archers draw
in there
on top of the wall at Casterly Rock
then we get a shot a couple of shots in
sequence but we hear little finger and
the voiceover he says everyone is your
enemy everyone is your friend and during
this we see your on rolling into town
dragging someone behind his horse in
King's Landing
we see Jaime and Cersei kissing we see
Daenerys turning around at Dragonstone
on the staircase and this scene we saw
in the spoiler so you can check that
video out if you don't know what's going
on here or if you want to stay spoiler
free you can do that too and we see the
silence and the iron fleet rolling at
night once again and we see Melisandre
in the same shot we saw her at
Dragonstone in the trailer but now we
see that Varys is actually there with
her he comes up behind her and stands at
her side we also see Masson Dee and grey
worm getting it on again we see a better
shot of Yara and Theon standing on deck
it looks like here is where the battle
at sea begins they look like they're
about to come under attack from Euron we
see is a shot of Daenerys walking up at
the beginning of when she first got the
dragon stone I think we've already seen
this in the episode we get that cut shot
again of the woman with the dagger on
what looks like a boat like I said I
think this is tyene sand and she's
stabbing something and we get a quick
shot of Arya who is looking a little bit
nervous she turns around in the shot and
she has a sort of unsettled look on her
face and then we cut to Littlefinger
talking to Santa and he takes back up
with his voiceover he goes on that every
possible series of events is happening
at once we see Tyrion at Dragonstone we
see that shot of people riding out of
Winterfell we see a fantastic shot of
Queen Daenerys standing on the staircase
again then we see Santa walking away
from the heart tree at Winterfell we see
me walking outdoors I don't really know
what's happening in this shot then we
cut to a bunch of quick scenes where we
see on Saleh falling from a ladder at
Casterly Rock then we see another dragon
in flight Jaime on the battlefield
getting ready to rally the troops in the
field you're on coming up he's got the
throne in front of Cersei it looks like
we see grey worm stabbing somebody which
is also a Casterly Rock we see the kiss
between Yara and Elora and then we get a
quick shot of Jorah Mormont and this
time we see him inside his room so we
can see that he's there it's really him
and that probably somebody's in there
talking to him most likely Sam and then
we see the Lannister soldiers clashing
with the unsullied which we've seen
before and then the biggest most
exciting part for me by far as we see
Daenerys and her people entering the
throne room at Dragonstone we get a look
at her and then we realize she's talking
to Melisandre or rather she's
approaching Melisandre and we hear the
last words which are Melisandre saying
to Daenerys I believe you have a role to
play as does another and yes it ends
right there so really cool I mean for as
little of new information that we got
the way that they cut it together and
the voiceovers tie a lot of things
together
obviously it's big to hear that John is
proposing an alliance with Daenerys in
front of all these people in Winterfell
obviously he's hitting a road bump Lord
Royce doesn't seem to be on board then
you have Lyanna Mormont saying winter is
here so she on Jon's side most likely
she always has been before so yeah we
see that unfold a lot closer than we
have we see Euron come back to King's
Landing and he has a very victorious
look on his face as he's riding through
town he obviously goes
and presents this gift which he looks
like he is bringing someone behind him
on the horse so it's a prisoner from
what we can tell not a whole lot of new
footage but like I said we see that
Varys was there with Melisandre when
she's looking over the castle there and
that she does make an appearance and
does present Daenerys with her help I
guess I mean that's what it looks like
it looks like she is saying look this is
what's happening it's not about that
iron throne it's about this war for the
dawn so we need to get on the same page
here I need you and I need someone else
which we know that she thinks John is
the prince at his promise so it's got to
be talking about John right so yeah it's
really cool sorry I didn't play the
whole thing I just don't want to get in
trouble but let me know what you thought
please like the video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel I've been
uploading new Game of Thrones everyday
since season seven started so definitely
check back soon follow me on my social
media accounts and thanks for watching
I'll talk to you soon